the Meandering Ohio River Winds its way
through a population of 25 million from
Appalachia through the Farms of the
Midwest before emptying into the
Mississippi the conservation group
American Rivers is named at 1500
kilometer stretch as one of the 10 most
endangered waterways in America there
are Health advisories as far as fish
consumption from the river is concerned
a lot of mercury pollution still is
contaminating fish we also have contact
warnings where people can't normally
swim and fish in the river
for the Wildlife and the human residents
of the Ohio River Basin sewage and toxic
runoff from farms and Industrial plants
have taken their toll
this is a working River lined with power
plants burning coal petrochemical plants
steel manufacturers and other polluters
each year they dump 18 million kilograms
of toxic chemicals into the Ohio River
Basin that's 20 percent of all the
chemicals released in American waterways
and that's why it's so dirty
there is hope for tainted waterways as
recently as 1997 American Rivers listed
Cincinnati's Mill Creek is the most
endangered Urban stream in America it
was in pretty desperate shape but after
25 years of very hard work with a lot of
great Partners it's made an amazing
comeback with fish and birds and
wildlife
but where Mill Creek now empties into
the Ohio River testing reveals a
waterway in crisis and drinking water in
danger unlike the Northern Great Lakes
Seattle's Puget Sound and Florida's
Everglades the Ohio River hasn't been
designated as a federally protected
water system which would open the door
to Restoration funding many
conservationists say the answer is to
make polluters treat their own toxic
waste rather than dumping it into public
Waters governments should say no we're
not going to allow you to pollute a
source of drinking water where our
citizens then will bear the costs but
with little funding less action and no
National plan there is scant hope of
restoring America's toxic waterways to
health anytime soon John hendron Al
Jazeera Cincinnati